olá quando eu fui convidado para
participar aqui do ted
eu fiquei muito orgulhoso e muito feliz
e quando eu vim conversar com a galera
quer saber como era o comércio sistema e
me perguntaram se explicando se eu seria
capaz de falar sobre um tema 18 minutos
eu estou feliz que é exatamente esse o
meu problema eu não consigo falar 18
minutos sobre o assunto
as minhas falas sempre tem 18 horas e
geralmente essas histórias delas tem um
começo muito muito animado um roteiro
bem empolgante mais fins intermináveis
cheios de bifurcações arrodeios então eu
vou pedir a colaboração de vocês aqui
pra que caso a gente veja um senso comum
que eu não vou conseguir concluir mesmo
18 minutos em um barzinho aqui na saída
da federal
estão todos convidados para terminar
isso lá inclusive que ela num bar que eu
ia começar essa história que antes de
jair é de vagando nessa nessa gracinha
porque foi um baque começou a minha
história com a comunicação num bar lá
nos anos 90 chamado soparia que rendeu
muita música muita conversa e histórias
não menos intermináveis mas o faria
foi só a conclusão da minha vida
acadêmica minha vida acadêmica começa
mesmo como como professor da
universidade católica de pernambuco
professor de capoeira mas era professor
porque eu fiz capoeira durante oito anos
seis só na unicap minha mãe dizia seis
anos na católica você fazia um curso uma
graduação e ainda fazia uma
especialização mestrado no mesmo lugar e
tempo e eu levei a sério aquilo terminei
o meu mestrado quer dizer que o quadro
saía mestre de capoeira da católica e
fui atrás de um rádio em doutorado
procure um balé popular do recife
e lá eu conheci a fundo que era a
cultura popular é ciranda frevo maracatu
caboclinho catira boi fui aluno fui
dançarino
o professor me formei cidadão e e depois
eu pra fazer se ter essa história que me
meter no teatro também por causa disso
eu tinha um emprego pra manter essa
minha vida acadêmica paralela para
divulgar toda a w é a era uma gravadora
que tem 36 anos
warner elétron e atlanta que tinha uma
música do mundo todo entre música
instrumental rock'n'roll dos anos 80
blues jazz e música popular brasileira
aquilo que obrigava a visitar rádios
diariamente é conhecer diz que joga de
casas noturnas
é a galera também os jornalistas
críticos de música me dava um
conhecimento a mais da cidade também não
é eu queria e mais além
resolvi juntar a isso tudo e convergir
toda a fauna e flora de minhas relações
diversas num único pós doutorado de
prazer então resolvi botava um barco
eu achava que se eu chegar naquele
naquele momento ali da minha vida é
porque realmente eu não tinha estudado
muito pra não chegar exatamente onde eu
não queria a a soparia era um objetivo
único de realizar um sonho coletivo que
é de viver sem trabalhar
esse sonho terminou virando uma uma
realidade essa realidade de um cotidiano
está atendendo quase me atropelou como
um pesadelo
abrimos de segunda a segunda fechávamos
as 67 da manhã pedindo desculpas
clientes que vão fechada
temos música todos os dias entre rock e
rolos chorinho forró ciranda maracatu
dança é poesia teatro radiola de ficha
mamulengo abril pro rock manguebit
makhoul maca cadeira de cadeiras já
estava lá fazendo exatamente
isso que eu faço até hoje juntando gente
é cuidar da vida da música e falando
pelos cruzeiros a soparia era tipo a uma
festa na minha casa
diária só que de noite é a gente era tão
o tipo de debate é tão espontâneo tão
honesto que pra mim era quase uma
deslealdade eu ganhar dinheiro com
aquilo
ela não dava lucro ea gente resolveu
fazer uma consultoria para saber qual
era o problema aí o consultor e traga um
lado pra gente dizendo que a gente era
um comércio é economicamente inviável
depois de alguns anos eu eu comecei a me
lembrar daqueles a que num ele não
estava de todo errado né a gente que
encomendou a história e falou a falou a
um tipo de negócio enganado
só parei não era um bar e restaurante a
gente já era um veículo de comunicação
pela própria convergência de destinos de
pessoas lhe de classe social diferente
de gênero de troca de informação através
da música e dos músicos que freqüentavam
dos projetos que se integravam entre
moda audiovisual a pelo próprio espaço
físico que tinha cartazes do da agenda
cultural da cidade quase toda empregada
nas paredes a ponto da galera passar lá
só pra saber o que estava acontecendo do
outro lado da cidade no recife que ainda
não tinha nem telefone celular na
internet na loja de conveniência fazia
da gente eu não vou dizer 11 facebook
não mas já éramos 11 a cut rústicos a
cadeira antes quando ba fechou eu pude
confirmar essa minha teoria porque
voltei a trabalhar normalmente fazendo
fazer um freelancer de fazer um filme
para um amigo meu que tinha acabado de
lançar um disco e fui na antiga rádio
cidade
é entregar o disco que conversar
encontrei a mesma diretora comércio de
diretor artístico e e ela começou
engatar um papo e eu comecei contato com
não sei por que um papa cumprido com ela
sobre música e ela falou poxa estou
conhecendo e sabendo da nova música que
está sendo feito em pernambuco dessa
pessoa como você que tratasse assunto
esse jeito com naturalidade e
conhecimento
eu faria um abrir a programação para um
programa assim se fosse ao vivo
você topa o cheio na hora o papel do
bolso assim com o nome sopa da cidade é
ainda estava quente ea partir daí é isso
tirou minha marca virou como se fosse um
rolo insere assim é sopa da cidade som
da sopa sopa diário sopa de auditório
sopa da oi sempre a mesma receita é os
mesmos ingredientes a música de
pernambuco dentro da do contexto da
música universal unmik aberto pra minha
opinião e para opiniões diversas e um
sotaque da cidade que não se ouvia nas
outras emissoras
e se esse negócio deu muito certo e as
pessoas gostaram muito desse formato de
comunicação alternativa à opa
estou fazendo comunicação como eu já
fazia mais só que agora é oficial estou
na área então a só queria mais queria
mais e queria pra mais gente também em
outros veículos também outras emissoras
não entendia e aí foi que eu conheci o
formato covarde e injusta tais
distribuição das concessões públicas de
rádio e tv no brasil pra grupos de
grupos de políticos e igrejas
os religiosos e passei a adicionei mais
um ingrediente na minha na minha sopa
que era a a militância na democratização
da comunicação
um tempo depois eu com a minha
popularidade já nos programas assim o
conhecimento
eu me juntei com a galera aqui é
historicamente conhecida por essa luta
também que a tv viva em olinda e fui
convidado pra
a cor a um programa deles em rede
nacional era o som na rural na tv brasil
a emissora rede pública de televisão
recém inaugurada pelo governo federal
como uma alternativa que de
centralização da informação na zona
rural era um carro uma caminhonete ford
rural ostomizados rodando pelo nordeste
mostrando a música ea cultura para o
brasil todo é foi muito legal foram mais
de 40 programas dois anos
e tava a velocidade estava boa mas aí a
mudança de governo enterrar vá às
engrenagens e e as a falta de certezas
indefinição na no financiamento também
atrapalhava aí quando a gente programa
começou a reprisar quando a gente tava
desanimando recebe a notícia que em
pernambuco o governador que é a tv
pública do estado lupa quer falar comigo
e com o grupo que eu fazia as
articulações da comunicação para aqui
fosse conduzido um processo nesse
sentido queria que eu encabeçasse essa
história remédio com dois e outro na
porta e eu topei e vamos nessa juntei
teórico é prático os militantes formamos
um grupo de trabalho abrimos o papo com
a sociedade
discutimos programação discutimos
orçamento previsão de lançamento
pensamos em auto sustentabilidade e aí
não dessa vez
o recife ele tem uma uma situação
geográfica que ajuda muita gente nessa
nossa persistência histórica é porque
sendo a gente é uma cidade que é abaixo
do nível do mar
nunca nos assustou essa ameaça de morrer
na praia é aí aí ea certeza de que as
marés sobem e descem a cada oito horas
não há clareza também saber que
democratizar a comunicação é
democratizar o poder isso o governo
nunca vai aceitar e nem querer dividir
não tem perigo a democratização da
comunicação está sendo feita de baixo
para cima e para os lados e sempre pra
frente ao mesmo tempo agora eles
voltaram para os gabinetes e nós
voltamos pra rua
é dessa vez sem sem gravação sem tv sem
transmissão será só uma só um carro
engraçado mesmo um as luzes um som legal
eo mick afinal de contas era isso que eu
sempre fui lá no começo por excelência é
juntar pessoas mostrar um som e vender
cerveja
vamos nessa eu posso dizer que a partir
daí com todo o morro e e e megalomania
colega lombra dodô
a gente passou a ser o maior programa ao
vivo da américa latina em linha reta
porque deixamos de ser uma um programa
de tv gravado ao vivo com música onde as
pessoas podiam também assistir e
passamos a ser uma ação de rua com
música é feita prioritariamente para as
pessoas e pensado para as pessoas
participarem
a gente podia gravar ou não é pra isso a
gente usou um método mais revolucionário
e que tecnologia nenhuma nunca vai
superar gente pessoas
a gente deixou de ser um programa ao
vivo pra ser na vera 10% do que a gente
conseguiu o conseg evitado que a gente
grava
jogamos na na rede e aquilo circula com
mais agilidade e mais objetividade na na
sua segmentação do que se estivessem
submetidos às inseguranças e
contradições da nova tv pública das
velhas tvs estatais ou é a líbia
aprisionados na num não as tvs
comerciais sendo cúmplice daquele
formato
é é ultrapassado e desonesto do ibope né
eu vou o que é ibope eo meu filho faço
não querer saber dessas coisas do
passado não vai responder os posts da
fan page que domingo tem tem evento do
som na rural porque o nosso público hoje
em dia ele após controle remoto
ele é coletivo ele é e inclusivo ele é
espontâneo ele não vai para a rua porque
é formador de opinião de que não muito
pelo contrário ele vai pra lá exatamente
porque ele quer mostrar e deixar bem
clara a sua e nada mais simbólico do que
um velho carro nacional para
ressignificar essa nossa vontade de novo
de rua o que teve um tempo que quase
faziam a gente convenceu o agente a
desistir das das ruas
o nosso literalmente veículo automotivo
de comunicação urbana agora mais do que
é e encontros musicais é um promotor de
manifestações públicas e ações políticas
que usam a sua ação política que usa a
música como instrumento a música como
vós ea rua como instrumento de
plataforma para a discussão da cidade
mais do que platéia agora nós somos
assembleias em praça pública
querendo mostrar uma reafirmar essa nova
forma de fazer política cantando
dançando dizendo poesia rindo e falando
bem alto a cidade que a gente quer
construir ou evitar o o som na rural ela
ele fundamenta se no artigo conceito das
das velhas veraneio de sons a usar
aquelas difusores das cidades do
interior que ficam na praça mandando
recado e tocando música
só que nossa praça agora que estamos
conectados é o mundo
participando detalhe da problemas
soluções efetivas de nossa cidade nosso
quintal
a gente também toma parte de discussões
de questões universais como difusores
nós somos veículos e como veículos somos
todos os motoristas agora de uma
comunicação sem freio e sem governo
criada por milhões de pessoas ao mesmo
tempo e em alta velocidade só que todas
na mesma direção e sentido é k a
liberdade agora ela é uma uma auto
estrada é de mão única a que num cada
curtida cada post cada fio é um posto de
gasolina e um motor de partida na
construção dessa avenida que não terá
cruzamento e nem meio fio só de simples
abaixo os vidros abram as portas
aumentem o som porque o som na rural
está no ar aliás nas ruas